[Music]
deliberate targeting of civilians
what is unquestionably a war crime
and in a hideous echo of the past the
illegal deportation
of people that the russian forces
believe are insufficiently sympathetic
to putin's aggression
and
in these circumstances
we can only
once again salute the heroism of the
ukrainian forces the bravery
of your armed forces and
in these circumstances vladimir i
completely understand
why you and your people can make no
compromise
with putin
because
if ukraine is suffering if ukrainian
troops are suffering then i have to tell
you that all the evidence is that
putin's troops
are under acute pressure themselves
and
they
are taking
heavy casualties
[Music]
that we are with you to give you
the strategic endurance
that you will need
and we are going to continue to help
intensify the sanctions on putin's
regime
we're going to do everything we can
to continue to strengthen the diplomatic
coalition of support around the world
for ukraine
and i
completely understand and sympathize
with the need for continued financial
support
for ukraine we're going to
work together
to liberate
the grain as you rightly say that is
being held hostage right now
by by putin depriving people around the
world of the food that they need and of
course
we will continue
as we have
from the beginning to provide the
military equipment
yes